GET A ROOM.
CRAIGSLIST IS NOT ONLY A GREAT
PLACE TO HAVE ONE-NIGHT STANDS
WITH MURDERERS, BUT YOU CAN ALSO
FIND APARTMENTS ON IT SOMETIMES.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU GUYS
PHOTOS OF AN APARTMENT, AND FOR
250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO COME UP
WITH A BETTER LINE TO SELL IT
THAN THE REAL TAGLINE, ALL
RIGHT?
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE-- BASEMENT
FOR RENT, FEMALES ONLY.
(LAUGHTER)
YES, SETH HERZOG?
>> ONE WAY IN, NO WAY OUT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS-- HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE, POINTS.
NEXT ONE-- $250 A MONTH, NOT AN
ACTUAL REAL BEDROOM.
IS THAT A... IT'S LIKE A PROMO
SHOT FOR HOARDERS.
YES, DOUG?
>> STUFF NOT INCLUDED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
WAIT, THIS IS CRAZY.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S A DOOR
UP HERE, AND THEN YOU JUST SORT
OF FALL ONTO THIS A PILE OF
GARBAGE.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE GARBAGE IS
THERE FOR, IS TO CATCH YOU.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: FREE BOX FAN.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, $200 A
MONTH, IT'S OUT THE ROAD, SO
MUST BE WILLING TO DRIVE.
IT'S IN HAWAII.
YES, MEGAN?
>> THE ONLY BUS YOU'RE LEGALLY
ALLOWED IT TO JERK OFF IN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WAY POINTS.
>> WOW.
>> THE GHOSTS OF CHILDREN ARE
FRIENDLY, RIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS FOR DOUG BENSON
FOR THAT.